franchement le premier gène qui qui sort
dès qu'on peut tous et toutes sortir
voilà c'est celui-là que je vais me
faire plaisir
[Musique]
j'ai un souvenir très fort de
l'extravagant docteur dolittle avec rex
harrison sont attachés des années 60 je
pense et l'escargot géant rose de faim
sur grand écran on avait fait une très
forte impression vraiment et puis une
autre séance haussier de ce cinéma qui
m'avait énormément marqué quand
j'habitais massy c'est oscar écoute
finesse c'est lors de la projection de
ngouye de bigas luna d'un film d'horreur
qui raconte l'histoire d'un psychopathe
qui tue les gens dans des salles de
cinéma ont leur découpant les yeux m de
rasoir autres comme ça et donc j'ai
passé un peu la séance à regarder
derrière moi pour savoir si ce dangereux
psychopathe était pas derrière moi stay
séances de films très très mal et dont
je vous conseille ce film riche de bigas
luna
j'aimerais bien voir je crois que j'ai
jamais vu sur grand écran berlin
enchanteur le dessin animé de walt
disney fin de wolfgang reitherman et
pour un film plus récents le spider man
in to the spiders gelé découvert en
blu-ray et g
regretter de ne pas l'avoir vu en salle
souci là ta merde et parce que
franchement je trouve le film dément et
ça j'aurai beaucoup beaucoup aimé le
voir sur un très grand écran avec du
très gros sont les animaux parlent dans
cette dimension
je voudrais pas qu'il ai la trouille
voilà je n'ai raté j'espère que je
pourrai rattraper ce retard armand mois
toutes les heures sont bonnes je peux y
aller le matin l'après midi le soir la
nuit peu importe ça dépend si je suis
seul si je suis accompagné ça dépend
quel genre de film independent humeur
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment besoin d'être centré pour
bien voir voilà l'image et entendre
toutes les variations dues sont donc je
dirais c'est plutôt un genre de septième
art au milieu ça dépend des salles bien
sûr c'est pas qui me viennent 10e on
dépend de la taille de la salle hop
c'est mon film j'aime bien les deux ça
dépend du film ça dépend de l'humeur
encore une fois moi tout me va
j'aime bien discuter d'un film après si
je suis accompagné j'aime bien digestion
sur l'eau si vous restez un peu avec le
film sortir marcher réfléchir ou
ressentir ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vu et
puis parfois concertée qui donc fait
absolument rien qui nous a fait plaisir
le temps du film mais qui n'en reste
rien c'est pas grave moi se manger un
truc après avoir un coup à toi bien
franchement le premier celle qui qui
sort dès qu'on peut tous et toutes
sortir voilà je suis là je vais me faire
plaisir que ça voudrait dire qu'on qu'on
peut se recroiser les uns les unes et
les autres dans des salles de cinéma
c'est ça qui est cool
voilà je finis russie d'accord